Mary here with a gamespot news update
thanks to the success of resident evil
HD it looks like Resident Evil 2 is also
getting an HD remake for modern consoles
a video was released announcing the
project revealing that it's being headed
up by the same producer of the resident
evil HD remaster released in January he
said you've been telling us for years
now that you want Resident Evil 2 to be
remade and we haven't been able to make
it happen until now his statement
indicated that the project is in the
very early stages of development and it
will be some time before Capcom can
bring you an update on this project it's
likely the decision to remake re 2 is in
response to a fan-made Resident Evil 2
remix which developed a following from
series enthusiasts and caught Capcom's I
Capcom then asked fans for their
opinions on a resident evil to remake
indicating it was considering the
undertaking itself a day later the
series producer confirmed he had pitched
Resident Evil 2 HD to his boss and
apparently the pitch worked this remake
should perhaps come as no surprise
Capcom said that due to digital
downloads of games HD remasters of our
catalog hit titles will be one of our
key business activities which Resident
Evil do you think will be the next game
to get an HD makeover my money's on
three stay tuned to gamespot com for the
latest